lab muffin is 10 years old the concept not me
this isn't some sort of weird leap year thing
in case you didn't know lab muffin started as a
blog before it expanded into
this youtube channel in 2017
the 10-year anniversary was in december my very
first blog post was on the 5th of december 2011
and my first "real" blog post was on the 9th
of december and that was called chemical versus
natural which was talking about all the myths
around natural beauty products which was like
the earlier fetus version of clean beauty now lab
muffin is my full-time job and i never thought
it would ever come to this it is pretty much my
dream job so thank you so much to everyone who's
been supporting me and making this possible i
asked everyone to send in questions they had
about lab muffins so this video is going to be
like a big overview of who i am how i got here
what i've learned on the way behind the scenes of
lab muffin sort of like how the sausages are made
in case you haven't already
subscribed do that like the
video and click the nerdification bell so
you get nerdified when there are new videos
biggest changes within the science skincare
community everyone knows a lot more of the
basics now which i like to think is partly because
of me and because of that i think people are a
lot more interested in knowing the details and
really understanding everything at a much deeper
level the really nice thing about this is that
i can talk about much deeper topics that i never
thought i'd be able to tackle things like the math
behind calculating whether or not you need indoor
sunscreen the mechanism behind how different
sunscreens work which is really incredible 30000
people watch me talk about electronic transitions
between quantized energy levels and that to me
is absolutely mind-blowing on the bad side i
think marketing myths have gotten a lot more
complex and sophisticated and so they've become
a lot harder to debunk and if you've heard of
brandolini's law which is also known as the
bs asymmetry principle you need to put in a
lot more effort to debunk stuff than to put out
garbage also maybe we care a little bit too much
about the details these days maybe we're getting
bogged down in things that don't really make a
huge difference at the end of the day a lot of the
time with skincare there just isn't a clear-cut
answer and the best thing to do is really just
look at reviews from people you trust and just
try things for yourself rather than trying
to logic it out from a scientific perspective
over the ten years name the top three most
infuriating myths you've heard i think number one
has to be sunscreen is causing more skin cancer
than the sun because this is just straight up
dangerous misinformation i live in australia and
i know a lot of people who have skin cancer now
and maybe they could have prevented that with
sunscreen there's also the whole beauty companies
are just trying to kill you because they want to
make more money thing that a lot of clean beauty
tends to promote this is one of the reasons i
started my blog it is basically just a big pharma
conspiracy theory but for beauty my mom falls
for this one a lot and that's another reason i
started my blog because i was going down all these
rabbit holes trying to convince my mum not to just
throw out all of her shampoo fear is a really
powerful emotion it's really fundamental to the
way that we humans evolved and i think it's just
so scummy when beauty brands try to exploit this
and manipulate you and make you feel really scared
to try to get a profit there's also the whole idea
that there's no science in cosmetics and there is
for example skin care is pretty much just applied
medicinal chemistry there are lots of reasons why
the evidence doesn't look as rigorous as maybe it
is or maybe it should be and a lot of that is
just because of the legalities around how skin
care is regulated this is the whole drug versus
cosmetic thing that i've talked about before
there just isn't a lot of incentive for companies
to actually run rigorous studies even if that
particular ingredient is really well supported by
the evidence so far and so this leads to a lot of
lazy debunkings things like saying collagen
cannot possibly work because they just didn't
bother doing a literature search that whole zinc
study where they looked at sunscreens but they
only looked as sunscreen technologies that are 30
years old i think a lot of this comes from this
idea that cosmetic science is female and frivolous
and so there can't possibly be any science in it
if you look at areas with lots of pseudoscience
but it's mostly male dominated things like gym
junkie bro science then cars and tech you see that
people are a lot more careful when they debunk
things there they take it a lot more seriously
and they do a lot more background research
they don't just go in there and assume they know
everything and yeah i think it does come down to
the idea that cosmetics is a lot more frivolous
and fluffy and there's just zero science there
even though we have these multinational companies
that hire lots and lots of scientists in cosmetics
negativity and hate most people are really
supportive skincare creators are generally
really nice i do tend to get more hate when i'm
doing myth-busting stuff because sometimes i am
talking about people's deep-seated beliefs it can
affect people's businesses so it's understandable
that people often have a pretty bad initial
reaction sometimes it's even just people who
are big fans of the brand maybe they've tried a
whole bunch of face creams and this is the one
face cream that works but the brand happens to
have a whole bunch of dodgy marketing sometimes
it's from people who did sponsored posts for a
product i criticized there was the propaganda
video that was when i got cited as a propaganda
source twice in a peer-reviewed article and he
sometimes comments on my blog as well it's very
strange with misrepresentation it happens a lot
and i think it's pretty unavoidable a lot of the
time my stances are pretty complex and it's pretty
easy to misrepresent them if they get summarized
i'm pretty sure i've misrepresented my own beliefs
i've had a science brand try to debunk my fatty
acids and oils video and they just used a whole
bunch of points that i addressed in the video in
terms of dealing with it it depends on the exact
situation if it's a common misconception then
i try to address it publicly or maybe if they
have a really large reach sometimes i reach
out to them privately and try to sort it out
that way and sometimes i think it's best to just
ignore it and like go out and touch some grass
do people in real life raise an eyebrow when
they find out i'm a skincare content creator
yes i think it's kind of 50-50 some scientists
especially those in academia think it's really
silly because of that whole there's no science
and cosmetics thing but a lot of people are really
supportive including a lot of my male scientist
colleagues who think it's pretty cool my boss
at my tutoring college who never uses social
media has been just so supportive he's always
helping me out with any physics questions i have
he lent me the thermal camera that i've been using
how do you decide which companies to work
with with my sponsorship selection process
the ultimate test is will people who can't buy
this product at all maybe they live in antarctica
will they get something useful or
interesting out of this piece of content
so obviously it has to be based on interesting
science it has to be scientifically accurate
and i have to actually like the product most
of the brands i work with are because i've used
their products before and i tried it and liked it
and posted about it and that's why they reached
out to me for a sponsorship if i haven't tried
the product before and i think i might like it
they have to send it to me and i try it before
i sign any contracts there are sponsorships
that have fallen through because even though the
product was perfectly good i just didn't like it
and that's because i think even if the
science is interesting and i explain it
at the end of the day people are going to ask me
do i recommend this product did i like the product
and i want to be able to say yes there's been
one exception where i didn't like the product
but they wanted me to make purely educational
content and that was pantene and that's just
because i'm allergic to the preservatives
they use so i can't actually use their product
have you ever faced a situation where sponsors
weren't happy with my scientific evaluation of
the product it's actually incredibly rare that i
get any pushback on the facts that i talk about
in a sponsored piece of content part of it is
that i'm really choosy with my sponsorships and
the brief is actually in the contract so you
can see it before you sign it generally this
is like in appendix a and if there's anything
in that that i'm not comfortable with if it's
not scientifically accurate if there's not enough
evidence for it then i'll usually ask for it to be
taken out of the contract if it's like a small
thing if there's way too much in there that i
disagree with then i just don't sign the contract
99% of the time the edits that i have to make
aren't actually factual most of the time i get no
edits so of the edits i've recently had to make
i've pronounced something wrong i got the price
wrong sometimes they want a particular shot
in the content so maybe i didn't show applying
the product or maybe the label got a bit blurry
a couple of times they've changed the packaging
since i shot it and they wanted me to reshoot
that content sometimes they want me to reword
things for legal reasons or include disclaimers
for example with sunscreens in australia
you have to have a particular disclaimer
i think once they didn't want me to
mention a competitor because they
didn't want to risk getting sued there is
one piece of feedback that i absolutely
hate that i've gotten a lot less pushback on and
that's changing the language of the disclosure
a few years back i used to always get feedback to
change sponsored to partner or collab but these
days it's gotten a lot less it's also a lot
easier to argue against now because australia
now has clear legal guidelines and i can point at
them and they know they can't negotiate with that
brands getting upset blacklisting me giving
me legal threats so after i criticize a brand
usually it's 50 50 whether they respond well
or badly some brands are really nice about it
they thank me they tell me they want to
do better and i'm sure sometimes it is
just lip service and we should hold brands
accountable for making these changes but
it definitely looks better from a pr perspective
it's much better than the alternative where they
respond really badly i've been blacklisted a
few times from different brands and different
pr companies one brand i criticized
contacted my management and reminded
them about their sponsorships with their
other creators which i thought was a bit much
how do you go about researching a new topic this
really depends on the topic and my process as
always is a little bit chaotic so let's say
i'm trying to talk about a new publication
my first step is to make sure i really
understand the background these days
it's a bit easier because i've done so much
background reading for everything else already
i would read through the paper really
closely sentence by sentence and look up
anything i don't understand usually this is by
looking through textbooks you do have to be a bit
careful with textbooks because they're sometimes
a bit of inaccurate stuff they're not really peer
reviewed so you do have to check against other
sources check against your existing knowledge
and check what experts think usually in this
process there are a lot of detours it is rarely
straightforward where i can just read a paper from
start to end it can take about six hours to read
through say a three-page paper i think a key part
for working out the correct direction for a topic
is just knowing who the right experts are for
example whether mineral sunscreens absorb or
reflect uv if you're a dermatologist it
doesn't actually matter to you which one
it is as long as the sunscreen works a physical
chemist would have to know because firstly they
would use different machines to measure the uv
protection if it reflected or if it absorbed
and secondly it has to do with the microscopic
structure of that chemical if you're trying to
work out if sunscreens cause or prevent skin
cancer then dermatologists toxicologists and
regulators would be really relevant but a physical
chemist or a coral scientist wouldn't be relevant
so i think it's really important to work
out whose opinion to give more weight to
which video took the longest there are videos
that have been sitting on the back burner for
months because they just won't quite come together
and i don't want to say the topics because i don't
want to give people false hope a lot of these
topics are things that people have suggested to me
so don't feel like every time you give me a
recommendation for a topic it just goes into the
ether i write them all down and someday i hope
to cover them all but yeah i am one person and
unfortunately things take a lot of time sometimes
it isn't even the volume of research that's tricky
sometimes it's collaboration basically every time
i do a collaboration i have to start a whole new
process and it takes ages trying to work out how
to edit people in without misrepresenting them
and still making the video flow together really
nicely out of the videos i've done so far probably
the longest ones have been the clean beauty one
which had dr fred editing his stuff down was
pretty tricky it took me months to work out how to
make it sit together but i'm really really happy
with final product and he was happy with it too
another video that took ages was the alcohol video
which had kind of stephen who i'm sure a lot of
you know that one took ages because we were trying
to research together while coordinating through
a google document between canada and australia so
that was just sort of like a logistical thing and
also we were sitting on it for ages trying to work
out what the best way to tell that story was as
well one of the videos where the research actually
took a really long time was the coral reef video
on reef safe sunscreens and that was because when
i made it there wasn't that much published about
it so i had a really difficult time trying to work
out what the general scientific consensus was so
i had to dig through mailing list archives through
emails between coral scientists these days it's
a lot easier because there have been new review
studies that have been published which confirm
what i worked out but yeah having to work out
what was happening in a topic that isn't really
entirely my field was really tricky the skincare
oils and free fatty acids video also took ages
because i had to skim through hundreds of papers
no one had really researched this topic directly
so i had to put it all together through studies
that accidentally gave me the info i needed
the octocrylene propaganda video was also quite
difficult because i was in a weird headspace
at the time i had a lot going on in my life
and you can sort of tell i got kind of ambitious
about it i was trying to make that whole taylor
swift meme sequence and yeah whenever i get a
really good idea and i really want to make it work
i generally don't have the skills to make it
work so that one required a lot of outside help
so i got a lot of questions about my educational
background in high school i was actually more
interested in arts i took drama history full unit
english for unit maths and chemistry i was good at
physics and bio but i wasn't as interested in them
and i just really liked chemistry i really liked
how chemistry explained a lot of things that i
saw in everyday life because everything could
just be linked back to the fundamentals of how
molecules interact with each other things like
why you get condensation on the outside of cold
drink why raindrops merge on a window why you get
bubbles from detergent why if you have dry pencil
lead it makes your hand dirty whereas like if you
have dry pen ink it doesn't how like different
painkillers worked so i went to a really academic
high school and we had these lunchtime chemistry
classes and my friend went to it so i tagged along
it was sort of like more of a social event for
me here's something that i think might be a bit
unexpected i don't think i started off naturally
good at chemistry but because i went to all these
extra lunchtime classes mostly to hang out with
my friends i got a lot of practice and then i
got good at chemistry i think that's actually why
i'm good at teaching chemistry because i have an
insight into what it's like to suck at chemistry
in australia there's a system where you get a mark
at the end of high school and then different
uni courses have different cutoff marks and so
there's this stupid idea of not wasting your marks
so a lot of people in my high school get pressured
into doing medicine or law and so i picked
combined law at sydney uni at the time it had the
highest entry mark so i wasted less of my marks
and a lot of my friends were doing law it seemed
like a respectable job and it's the top law school
in the country i combined law with science for two
reasons the main one was when i was 17 science
sounded like something that would be a bit more
of a useful degree than arts also because i went
to those lunchtime classes i ended up being top
20 in the state for chemistry olympiad and that
meant you could actually skip first year chemistry
so basically my approach was i picked subjects i
was somewhat interested in and potentially had a
career after it and if i could get higher marks
without as much effort then even better so my
science courses were chemistry psychology maths
pharmacology and physiology so the idea was i
could become a patent attorney or potentially go
into drug design i was really fascinated by how
different substances could have like really
different effects on your body so different
things could get you to stop sneezing or stop your
headache or hallucinate or drop dead um my parents
are nurses so when i was a kid i got a lot of
random stuff given to me when i was sick so after
the first three years of undergrad i paused law
for a year to do honours in chemistry i ended up
dropping law because even though i love studying
law it turns out i hated working in a law firm the
project i was working on was where my law firm was
representing a tobacco company and i never really
considered myself a super moral person i assumed
if i got paid enough then i would be comfortable
giving fair representation to any party because
that's what all lawyers should be doing but it
just slowly ate away at me that i was working
so hard and the harder i was working the more
i was helping what to me seem like the bad guys
win there's no judgment for me for people who do
this kind of work i have a lot of friends in law
and i think detachment is a really useful skill
but it just isn't the way i'm built so because of
that experience i'm a big believer in trying out
lots of different things if you think you might
be interested in something then just try it out
because you don't really know what it's like
unless you immerse yourself in that experience
if you can't get practical hands-on experience
then try to talk to people who work in the fields
that you might want to go into so hopefully you
get a better feel for what actually interests you
and what you enjoy doing and whether or not that
field matches that so i discovered that a lot of
people become patent attorneys after getting a phd
so doing a phd seemed like a good way to keep both
of those patent attorneys drug design parts open
my phd was a continuation of my honours project
which was really interesting it was on medicinal
and supramolecular chemistry i also made a lot of
friends with my cohort and a lot of us decided
to continue our phd so that was a really nice
group of people to be around there was also
the fact that the admin to change unis let
alone countries was just a lot i'm really bad with
dealing with admin and staying at sydney uni was
just like filling in two pages so that's the not
very inspiring story of how i ended up doing a phd
what made you decide to go the scicomm route and
not stay in academia i've always really enjoyed
teaching so during my phd i did a bit of lab
teaching and i also taught tutorials to undergrads
i also did a lot of tutoring before this so my
first tutoring job was at 14 and when i was a
kid i actually remember inventing multiple choice
tests for my friends to do so that they could join
a club yeah i was just a really annoying child so
there's just not that much teaching in academia a
lot of academia just revolves around research but
a lot of scicomm is pretty much like teaching so
that's another reason why i started lab muffin
at the time people told you that if you wanted
to go into scicomm you should start a blog as
like a portfolio and it could really show that
you were truly interested in scicomm so i think
the main thing that got me out of thinking of
academia as a long-term job was that there was a
fire in my lab in 2012 it was the final year of my
phd and i was in the lab where the fire was and i
pretty much just saw my life flash before my eyes
our labs were organized so that all the organic
chemists were on one level and organic chemistry
involves a lot of really flammable solvents so you
can basically imagine it was just a lab where on
top of every lab desk there was just a bunch of
petrol in my mind in that moment i thought the
whole building would just go up in flames i could
just see a wall of flames just like exploding
towards me it didn't the fire was actually
confined to a really small area but that incident
affected me a lot i had ptsd for about six months
i had nightmares every single night when i went
back near that building i got this really
uncomfortable like skin crawling feeling and
it made finishing my phd really difficult i didn't
publish as many papers as i probably could have i
took a bit longer than i should have as well that
incident really highlighted that i love chemistry
but not enough to die because someone else screwed
up so after i graduated i didn't really know what
to do i lived in switzerland for half a year with
my partner at the time i got really depressed i
worked on my blog i became a moderator on
/r/skincareaddiction on reddit i started
teaching at matrix education to earn some money
on the side this is a tutoring college that does
usually classes of 15 they hire a lot of phd
students and they paid really well and about six
months later they offered me a full-time position
as a chemistry coordinator so i was in charge of
hiring teachers teaching and writing the teaching
materials so i was writing the textbooks and
inventing experiments and so i sort of just fell
into that role and i found that i absolutely loved
it i stayed there until i went full time with lab
muffin and i still teach there a few hours a week
where did the name lab muffin come from this story
is just not that exciting um so i knew i wanted to
do a blog i couldn't think of a name and so i
couldn't really start doing my blog for about
four weeks and i knew i just had to start so i
settled on lab muffin i was sitting in a lab at
the time when i set up my first blogspot account
muffin was the nickname from my partner at the
time i told myself i could just start and then
change the name later and i just never thought up
a better name and i never got around to changing
it so the good thing about the phrase lab muffin
is that it is like a brand new sentence which
means it's very search engine friendly so back
in 2012 if you typed in lab muffin into google i
would be the first result so if you're trying to
pick an online handle and you want to be very
easily searchable i would definitely recommend
something relatively unique and easy to spell lab
muffin worked really well for that if you have a
really distinctive name then i would just go with
your name but that wasn't an option for me because
there were literally 27 other michelle wongs
back when i tried to sign up to hotmail in 1997
how did your phd slash degree help you with your
career and what did you have to learn yourself
so my phd project was on cyclic peptides
i was making them and then exploring their
uses as drugs and supramolecular scaffolds so
that combined with my undergrad subjects gave
me a really good background understanding of
things like chemistry pharmacology physiology
and medicinal chemistry so from that i was
really used to looking at things like ligands
and biochemical pathways but i never really
looked at anything like retinoids specifically
so i think more importantly i developed a lot
of other skills from my phd training and from
my previous job during a typical phd you have
to defend your ideas against people who are
kind of trying to make you break it's a bit toxic
some people cry but you kind of get used to having
to really critique your own ideas so that you can
work out all the flaws before you go up on stage
and have to publicly defend yourself writing
the textbooks was also really good training
because the audience was both chemistry
phds and phd students who are teaching it
and the high school students so you had to
make it work for a lot of different people
when did you realize you could go full time
as a science communicator so in 2017 i added
banner ads to my blog and that's when financially
i started making more money than i was spending on
lab muffin and that's when it started looking
like it could potentially be a part-time job
i was starting to get over a thousand dollars a
month without a ton of effort and i really wish i
discovered this a lot earlier on and not six years
in so yeah i guess my advice would be if there's
a hobby that you love doing see if you can make
money out of it earlier on in late 2017 i started
my youtube channel and that's when i started to
get a lot more sponsorship opportunities and the
workload started to really ramp up by late 2018
i was working on lab muffin on the train to and
from work and every weekend i pretty much had
no life i worked like 70 to 80 hours a week
i was basically in lockdown before lockdown was
a thing my accountant didn't actually believe how
many hours i worked until i showed her my records
every sunday monday which was my weekend i'd
literally get out of bed stumble across the room
to my chair and then work straight from 9am to 1am
i went out of my room for meals and for bathroom
breaks and that was it i do not recommend this
at all i recommend trying to figure out a way to
avoid this as early as you can by the middle of
2019 i was making enough money from content
creation that it could be a full-time job
and i was just about to burn out from working
every single waking moment i was constantly
shallow breathing i had a racing heart my memory
was getting really bad and i was starting to get
these like weird feelings in my legs like i
was getting little clots so i resigned um i'm
still not really good at that whole work-life
balance thing but it has gotten a lot better
so starting out and staying motivated i think one
of the things that really kept me going was having
a nice community around me there were a lot of
other bloggers back in the day and we all used
to comment on each other's blogs not in like an
organized way but just being really supportive
there wasn't like an algorithm
back then so we weren't really like
boosting each other's posts like you might
on instagram it was just like a really nice
supportive environment there was also this nail
polish tag that was going around back in the day
and every week we would have artsy wednesday
where we would have a different nail art theme
and i think these sorts of techniques
still work in the age of social media
just having lots of support and working on nice
collaborative projects i also just felt like the
content i was making just needed to be made no
one else was making this sort of thing back in
the day so things like scientific deep dives and
myth busting in a way that's accurate but also
people could really understand but on the other
hand there was a lot of pseudoscience going around
and so i kind of felt like this sort of i
guess duty to keep making my sort of content
how do you get started as a cosmetic chemist is a
phd necessary was it difficult so cosmetic chemist
is a qualification and i did my diploma
for this with the institute of personal
care science it's a very popular program
that's widely recognized in the industry
you definitely don't need a phd to do it
i think you need the equivalent of a high
school certificate it is definitely harder to
understand what's going on without some sort
of science background and you probably won't
get as deep an understanding out of it but
it is definitely doable and if you're
interested i would highly recommend it
what makes you happiest about doing youtube
and lab muffin i'm just a bit of a massive
nerd i love understanding stuff at a
really deep level and then explaining
it to other people i also really love
the whole creative process of creating
content whether it's presentations
or diagrams or textbooks or videos
what would you say is the most important part
in translating science to the wider population
i think accuracy is obviously really important
but also empathy just understanding what level
of complexity people can handle what analogies
would work best for explaining something and
what feels satisfying because what tends to
work really well for myth busting is giving
people a narrative that makes more sense than the
myth you have to help replace that with the truth
what did you study to improve the
delivery of your blog posts and videos
i think this is one of those things where the
best thing you can do is just practice a lot
just make content get feedback and then
incorporate that into your next piece of content
i think teaching is also really helpful because
it's like delivering content and getting that
real-time feedback and this doesn't have to be
formal teaching you could just try explaining
the topic you're trying to make content
about to your friends or to your family
what are the pros and cons of writing versus
videos so i started making videos because
i felt a bit constrained by blog posts some
things are just really hard to show you really
sort of need an animation or something moving
videos do take a lot longer though minus the
research a blog post would take about three
hours whereas a video would take 20 hours
difficulties with using social media
i think the most annoying thing about
social media is that you have to make the
algorithm happy to get any sort of reach
your posts don't get shown to your audience
unless you tick off a whole bunch of boxes which
change all the time and that might not be the best
thing for that particular piece of content maybe
you need to have a static post with lots of words
but the algorithm wants you to make videos social
media is also pretty intrusive it's designed to
make you want to check it all the time and so
if that's part of your work then your work-life
balance is a bit messed up it's particularly bad
because i'm in australia and so the peak times
for social media are weird hours for me things
like 2am on the other hand i do kind of like that
the algorithm changes all the time because i like
a challenge i have a short attention span
and so i like making lots of diverse content
what are the best and worst parts of your job i
think the best thing is that i'm quite a creative
person and so my job is just my entire creative
outlet if you get bored of doing the same thing
all the time then this job is fantastic the worst
thing is that the harder you work the more you're
rewarded and so that is really bad for work-life
balance also because it's like an internet job
it constantly feels really insecure like the
algorithm might screw me over at any moment
and i would no longer have a job i don't think
this is unique to making content or being a
science communicator i've heard similar things
from a lot of people who own their own businesses
and there are also content creators and science
communicators who are doing it as part of
a full-time salaried job and so they won't have
the same issues one of the things that really
helped me with time management is an app called
toggl i use it to record how much time it took
me to do particular things and so that way
i can better estimate how long it's going to
take me to do similar things in the future it's
really good for not over committing yourself
microphones software camera lights i'm going
to take you on a little behind the scenes tour
alright so here is my filming setup this is my
blue microphone it's a yeti x which was gifted
that is running into a laptop on my left in front
of me i have my old s8 which is what i film on it
is currently attached to an ice pack because
it's really hot today and it kept overheating
that's connected to a teleprompter you can see
my old phone there as well reflecting into that
this teleprompter has been really
good i've only had it for a few months
and it's made my video making so much quicker
because of the teleprompter means i can't actually
touch my phone so my phone is attached to my
tablet so this is connected with samsung flow and
so i can control the phone through this tablet
this is my lighting situation i have a softbox
and behind that i have i don't know this like
led array that led array lights up my background
and that's also why sometimes my face looks
lighter than the rest of my body because the
light from that gets blocked off by the softbox
i'm sure you've seen my background a million times
and the reason there's so much clutter around
here is actually i tried to have a really nice
empty studio but it turns out having lots of
stuff around is really good for audio quality
i don't know if anyone's noticed this but i have
a little box here that's just full of spatulas
what platform is most lucrative for you is
blogging truly dead so this might be a bit
surprising but my ad income is actually much
better from my blog than youtube even though i
spend so much more time on youtube there are lots
of blogs that are doing way better than me as well
especially food blogs i do think it's a
little bit harder to get established as
a blog these days because google does rank
you higher if you've got an older website
so if you are planning to start a blog then
i would recommend doing it alongside social
media because discoverability is a lot better
on social media in terms of sponsorships i get
the most money from instagram because
i can produce a lot more sponsored
instagram content than i can with youtube
videos youtube videos take so long to make
is there a point where skincare can become
obsessive or unhealthy definitely i think a lot
of people overthink skin care it's easy to just
take the scientific evidence too seriously in skin
care a lot of it is just not that clear-cut the
evidence is really weak and i feel like a lot of
myths come from just overthinking that evidence
whenever you see a strict rule for anything
usually that's pretty suspect because there
aren't that many studies out there on non-medical
skin care in science you generally need lots of
replicated studies to be sure about things and
that just doesn't really exist in skincare i think
a lot of the time getting obsessive about skin
care is more of a symptom and it's not skin care
causing the obsession a lot of people who come to
skin care come there because of self-esteem
issues and skin care just becomes an outlet
what have you believed in the
past that turned out to be myths
pretty much every older myth i've debunked i've
probably believed for example sunscreen scattering
and reflecting uv this doesn't happen as much
anymore because over the years i've become a lot
more cynical and so now if there's any new claims
i just start off not believing it by default
so i got a lot of questions about my future plans
and i do have some ideas for things that i really
want to branch into but i don't want to say too
much because again i don't like mentioning things
that i'm working on because i have so many ideas
that i just don't take through to completion i do
think i manage to do a decent amount of stuff
but there is only one of me and so it's really
hard to get everything i want done i do not have
plans for a skincare line maybe in the future i
could see myself collaborating with someone but
i don't think i can start my own line because
i would just end up spending all day doing stuff
that i don't like in other words just doing admin
hopefully this video was interesting
and gave you an insight into how
lab muffin works it would be really sad if i
released this video and then quit in a month
but hopefully that doesn't happen hopefully
there will be a 15 year video as well thank
you so much to everyone who's been supporting
me and allowing this to become my full-time job
especially if you've been following since back
with the blog days back when i used to do nail art
i think it's really cool that we've built
up this nerd community over the last decade
and hopefully it keeps going